e
multipliait. C'est ce qui en
ressort beaucoup quand on parle
d'ailleurs avec les résidents.
- Ici,n n trie les denrées
alimentaires. On les organise
puis on en reçoit davantage.
C'est une vraie fourmilière.
Car ces provisions doivent
s'envoler rapidement pour aider
les sinistrés des inondations
et les communautés autochtones
isolées.
Une grande opération logistique
possible grâce à Shaun Bradley
Heaps, proprtataire du club
d'aviation West Coast Pilote
Club.
"Un ami et moi sommes partis
survoler les régions éloignées
quand les inondations ont
commencé. On a vu des gens
en détresse. On a atterri pour
les aider."
Le constat sur le terrain
l'a poussé à continuer.
Il a contacté des amis
propriétaires d'avions pour
solliciter leur aide.
De bouche à oreille, en moins
de deux semaines, l'aviateur
a constitué une flotte de
55 avions et cinq hélicoptères.
Et qui dit plus d'avions dit
plus de pilotes. L'aviateur
peut compter sur des amis, des
bénévoles, comme Samuel Daigle.
SAMUEL DAIGLE
pilote, Fort Langley Air
- J'ai les compétences et
les habiletés pour le faire.
Donc, pourquoi ne pas utiliser
ça et aider la communauté.
- Il a même eu besoin de
louer un deuxième hangar.
Si les avions sont prêtés,
que les provisions sont offertes
généreusement et qu'une armée
de bénévoles est au rendez-vous,
il reste à payer l'essence.
"Mes cartes de crédit sont
pleines. J'ai payé plus de
15 000 $. On reçoit des dons
en argent, mais ça ne couvre pas
tout."
Un seul déplacement
de deux heures en hélicoptère
peut coûter jusqu'à 700 $.
Shaun, ancien pompier, aime
visiblement toujours éteindre
des feux.
Plusieurs ici comme Samuel
déplorent le manque de soutien
des gouvernements.
- C'est un peu plate de voir
que le gouvernement n'est
pas vraiment là pour nous aider.
- Un constat partagé par Shaun.
"Justin Trudeau est allé dans
ces communautés autochtones
isolées la semaine dernière
avec trois hélicoptères sans
provision, mais remplis
de journalistes."
En survolant la région,
on constate bien les défis.
Les routes sont parfois
accidentées. D'autres fermées
ou sont à risques de glissement
de terrain. Nous voilà arrivés
à Boston Bar, dans
la vallée du Fraser.
Carly Tompson travaille pour
le service des incendies du coin
et elle distribue aux familles
les provisions généreusement
livrées.
La femme est époustouflée
par toute cette solidarité.
Elle est moins loquace lorsqu'on
lui demande de qualifier l'aide
reçue des gouvernements.
"Heureusement que Shaun et
son équipe sont là", dit-elle.
L'arrêt dure quelques minutes
à peine, car d'autres attendent
l'oiseau comme un ange venu
du ciel.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Langley